the Joe Rogan experience mm-hmm like you
get when I go over the Asia ad
everything moving do you see that
there's a video to like a hundred my
kids explain this to me I didn't know
about this
it's called mukbang what's that it's a
style of video that they do in Korea
where Korea like I guess their proper
and polite when they eat that's you know
they have good manners they try to do
that culturally so they have these
videos that are real popular where they
just eat like slobs
they'll eat like octopus no and they
have the just splatter food all over
their face and make a lot of noises
while they chew and these videos are
insanely popular millions and millions
of views are people watching someone eat
that's cuz it's well you can't go by
they are view of millions and they view
ain't that much because you got think
it's billions of them I mean that's true
but there's not billions of Koreans but
I guess it's it's a lot of how many
Koreans are there that's Google it's a
small country relatively hey Syria how
many uh how many Koreans that day out
you how many Koreans population out you
I don't know that you know let me just
do the paper right tap type at the old
house yes
population Korea 50 million 50 million
what are you have to be one point fifty
one point four seven that's a lot and
how many is America's 330 so it doesn't
know so it's more of us they don't know
how many Mexicans are they do not they
do not you'll never figure they're never
gonna figure that out and let you go to
a concert look
[Applause]